we lived on Rector Street I moved in on
September 1 2001. oh 10 days into my
tenure I was woken up because all the
windows glass blew it hey like our whole
apartment exploded [__] and like God
your son wasn't I was like thank God he
wasn't ready and I like I just remember
like panicking and like putting on
shorts I'm not like they're up like what
do we do and I was like I'm getting the
[__] out of here and they're like do not
leave the house the worst thing you can
do and I was like all right [__] that
I'm I'm Elite like good luck guys and I
bailed and I went outside and it was
just like it was like like PTSD is
something special because I'm friends
with a lot of former soldiers my kid
brothers are a veteran I don't use that
lightly but like I could describe for
you in the most Vivid detail yeah like
if I could I could export this if I
could draw I could paint for you a frame
by frame 24 frames per second what I
experienced for the proceeding four
hours with the most Vivid smells tastes
colors everything yeah like stepped
outside of my apartment and I just see
someone frantically not in uniform a
human just [__] dressed like you were
running around frankly with a stack of
sheets this High taking the sheets with
one hand wring it out and then dropping
them and I'm like what the [__] is that
person doing and as they drop them
they'd turn red and I realize they're
dropping their sheets on remains that
had fallen
and when I realized that my brain just
no no no nothing could remains of human
beings that had fallen from the plane
no to cover them oh [__] I think you're
talking about like
bed sheets
and like my brain like you now I
couldn't understand that yeah and then I
definitely couldn't understand and I
just like got on my bike and like I had
my video camera and I was like trying to
bike away and I stopped and I just see
like all these cops running and I say
paper falling and it's like could not
make sense of it and then like a fire
engine starts screaming I'm like get out
of here like for my own safety it was
not being a jerk and I was like start
biking away and then just like
like heat like you never imagined just
throws me off my bike and that was the
second like second plane hit it like
skin my knees get up and like race to
Van's apartment on 14th Street and I get
van like like what do we do and I was
like we gotta go to the hospital and
we're gonna go help people and like we
went to Saint Vincent's they sent then
since rest in peace this has been closed
down and turned into overpriced
Condominiums and we were like out front
there and like helping and I just
remember like no one knew what to do
yeah and we're like the cops showed up
and the cops were like who's in charge
who's in charge and I was like what's
the question and they're like what do we
do yeah and I was like I need you to
shut down that street shut down traffic
here shut down traffic here only let the
ambulances through create a way for the
ambulance come through you have flares
they're like they're in the trunk I was
like get the flares and I was literally
on New York one like [__] commanding
the situation as like a 20 year old
outside of Saint Vincent's because there
was just nothing and I remember like the
one thing I was like is like we have to
start lining [__] up and they're like
we're out of cuts and I was like get
rolling chairs put sheets over line them
up we like all this they're like
everybody was ready and no one came like
there was no one to be saved and I was
like that's where I was standing like
you know that view on Sixth Ave looking
straight down at the World Trade Center
right there and I just like stand there
in slow motion watching them fall and it
was like CGI before CGI it was like so
like this flower there was like a beauty
to it that was like it was like you're
again you're watching you're like I
don't know what I'm seeing but that's
not
that's and that's not real it's too
crazy for you to even comprehend yeah
yeah did you film any of it I mean like
I have a couple shots of me biking away
and I made videos about it but like I'm
biking away and the camera's behind me
at one point in time I switch hands and
it crosses my face you go through it
frame by frame and you just see like the
terror yeah wow on my face yeah so in
any event that was cool
and I remember that moment affected the
way you viewed creation or like the way
you lived your life after that like it
is a dream how does that change you no I
mean I remember like vividly calling
like my dad like I called like my kid's
mom like crying I was like get him out
of school she's like Casey's fine yeah
he's fine now like I called my dad and
my dad was like it's time to come home
it's time to come back to Connecticut
and I just remember like being like what
are you talking about I dare you like no
I'm not coming back and then I called
the the husband of the cousins that we
lived with because he was sort of a
mentor and he was like it's time to come
back and I was like I'm not coming back
yeah and I was like no this is it like I
can make it through this then I'm good
like I'm good yeah that was when I got
like the SRO and like I started to
figure it out after that like it started
to make sense after that yeah